your Danielle you're out in the world
but people see you and recognize you
that they're fans of the show that must
be quite an experience yes it is it is
crazy we have the coolest most bold fans
I mean it's a little insane I've had
someone come up to me in the car like my
window is down and you're in the car and
your windows down I'm at a stoplight
right and they roll up to me they run to
the car and kiss me on the cheek it's
crazy
I do that to just women in general
ladies I'm telling you if I see an open
window I'd go for it
Tania right now so so that's what about
you you you ran to a couple recently one
recognize even one didn't yes so I was
at the ATX festival in Texas and I'm
walking down the street with some
friends and these two went white women
come up and we cross paths and one of
them says Kelly I think that's tasty and
the other one says don't be racist
you went back and I said it is me you're
not racist and I took a picture with
them and they what's really really
that's so great don't be right